[Applause]
now for populist demagogues to liberal
elites fox news to the BBC the warring
tribes of our troubled world agree on
few ideals and still fewer facts yet
they all share the belief that they are
right are we all suffering from the
illusion that we can uncover the truth
should we embrace the world of competing
facts while still seeking a progressive
and stable society or do we need grand
new narratives to help us escape a
dangerous relativistic world we've got
three people here on the platform to
help us on my right is Hilary Lawson
who's then non-realistic philosopher
best known for his theory of closure
he's the founder of the eye a eye and
how the light gets in for Mason who's
the former economics editor for both
Channel 4 News and the BBC's Newsnight
Paul is the author of post capitalism a
guide to our future and Della McPherson
his co-director of the center of
government and human rights
she's Cambridge University lecturer in
sociology of new media and digital
technology so are we all suffering from
the illusion that we can uncover the
truth Hilary Lawson Thank You Roger well
I guess my my brief answer is yes I
think we are at risk of suffering from
the illusion that we might uncover the
truth and I guess the real question I
think is will why are we so attracted by
this illusion I mean truth is such a
beguiling word it seems to offer so much
as if we might be able to arrive at
fully understanding how things are and
it enables us to end conversations you
know well that's just true and it
enables us to justify actions we can say
both both both the terrible actions and
the good ones it's on a personal level
truth is beguiling but it's also being
beguiling at a social level truth was
central to the Enlightenment to the idea
of gradually uncovering knowledge and
discovering how it is to
to the idea of social progress that we
were going somewhere that we might
arrive somewhere so truth has indeed
been a particularly beguiling idea but
I'm going to argue that it is an
illusion
it's a fantasy and it may be a powerful
fantasy it may be in a sense a valuable
fantasy but it's a fantasy nevertheless
and I think that I'm going to argue that
that's because our language and our
theories and our stories about the world
are not descriptions we imagine them as
being descriptions of stuff out there I
don't think that's what's going on our
language and our accounts of the world
on our narratives are tools to enable us
to do things they function by taking
what I would call the openness of the
world and holding it in specific ways
and we hold a world in a particular way
and as a result of that we're able to do
different things with it so if I say you
know at this class you can say well what
sort of glass is it is it is it fragile
is it whatever it would it be but I
might say it's not a class it's actually
a collection of silicon atoms in which
case I'd have a rather different series
of questions that would follow from that
account you know what's the array of the
silicon atoms what's the what's how do
they function or I might say about it
it's an example in a talk in which case
the question is well did it was it did
it work as an example was it effective
was it not effective so the way that we
close the world changes how we intervene
with it and our choices are not between
the correct description which is
impossible because language is a tool
and you wouldn't say do you have the
true computer you might have a better or
worse one or do you have a true
lawnmower and know you have a better
lawnmower or a worse lawnmower but you
don't have the correct one and I think
the same thing is is the case with
our language and I think we can despite
that there are only tools we can refine
those tools if we have one it doesn't
quite work then we can see how it
operates and change how it works to try
and get it to work better
are we all suffering from the illusion
that we can uncover the truth Paul if
you want to categorize me I am a Marxist
ok and what we think is that we solve
the prop or we try to solve the problems
that you've outlined there in the
following way the assumption is that the
reality our brains are recording is real
and that our brains are a part of that
reality that is we I am am honest I
believe there is there is no soul or
intelligence separate than matter and in
the process of recording this matter in
my brain there are two sort of added
bits that historical materialism brings
to the question of how we know things
epistemology one is that it says the
process of knowing is active its
interactive with the world and not as in
a manual count a sort of passive sort of
a photography paper trying to record
what's going on the way I know that that
the physics of an aeroplane alright is
that I can write them down and together
with someone the other side of the world
we can both try and fly the aeroplane
according to its rules and it will
generally generally fly so it is not
passive cognition there is an active
cognition the second part is it is a
social cognition I just described on
purpose it wasn't me predicting what how
the aeroplane would would work it's me
and a lot of other people no you are
quite right that we evolved language as
a way of representing the world it as
our brains perceive it and you are also
quite right that our modes of perception
depend on levels of abstraction
therefore the glass is a glass at the
level of abstraction of physical reality
of molecular it's it's sand and whatever
else today is a quantum physical level
it you can't even touch it
without changing it but what's the
impression far are we still suffering
from the illusion that we can
the truth therefore it is not an
illusion that one can have accurate
knowledge but the knowledge itself -
first first thing the reality itself is
in flux reality itself is always
changeable so the attempt to capture it
in a series of syllogisms a equals a
that is a glass and so is that well no
they're different things they're
actually decaying at different rates
because reality changes first of all the
second thing is for me for Marxist the
truth is also contradictory that is if I
say if somebody asks me what is
neoliberalism what is the system we live
in I will say it's a thing that's
falling apart for me truth is a quality
of human thought not a quality of
reality that is it I can say I will
never say there is an absolute truth so
my job as a journalist is to fight it so
first of all try to record facts as I
see them I think that can be done that
doesn't mean of I've achieved truth but
it does I do think that one can make
accurate and testable statements about
reality that we have codified over 400
odd years into the scientific method it
difficult and problematic though the
scientific method is the reason it is
under attack now which is what I think
we won't want to talk about soon when
we've all done this is because of of a
project of irrationalism in which a
certain section of humanity actually
wants to try and deny the possibility of
accurate percent alright let me put one
last question here for you so are you
saying there are facts no and there are
certainly facts they exist in books of
facts but facts are up are fact it
weirdly as a materialist I will agree
with you that language is simply a an
attempt to frame things of the word fact
is one of them well no hologram is
reality reality exists yeah so to the
extent that reality is truth truth
excellence are our perception of the
reality it may be impossible for us to
be to perceive reality fully but
underneath but underneath that is a
reality are you saying there is the
reality is out there it all
our attempts at cognition are always
inadequate because that somebody will
always do better you know the the
Copenhagen interpretation comes on top
of Maxwell comes on top of Newton it's
always gets better and therefore I do
not expect it was able to achieve stasis
with a we have no perceived phenomenon a
as true as it's gonna get
number one but in the process of
perceiving phenomenon a has moved into a
plus one and so it's just that I'm I'm
dwelling at the level of epistemology
because it's not often you hear Marxists
do this because they are also interested
the class struggle but because I think
that it is it was this mode of thought
came out came precisely out of a
critique of of both duelers and mind a
matter and attempts of materialism that
could not explain change and indeed
could not explain
falsification right I've come back and
went to a number of those issues Ella
can I bring you back to that first
question that you that we've asked you
to address which is are we all suffering
from the illusion that we can uncover
the truth great ok good question I agree
with the illusion part but my answer to
the question is no along three
dimensions first it's with respect to
this notion of we all are we all
suffering from this know some people are
suffering from this and these are the
people who traditionally have been used
to establishing the truth right the
truth that we all agree with that we all
accept scientists academics politicians
journalists that kind of thing right
which if we think about it for example
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas